all makers the intelligence community
and the Trump administration are dealing
with a new potentially explosive issue a
whistleblower complaint over an alleged
promise made by President Trump to a
foreign leader the case is shrouded in
mystery and was the subject of a
closed-door classified meeting today on
Capitol Hill the president is already
pushing back and the house Intel chair
is threatening to go to court chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge has the latest tonight behind
closed doors on Capitol Hill the
intelligence community Inspector General
Michael and concern briefed Republicans
and Democrats on the House Intelligence
Committee the Democratic Chairman said
the session did not confirm media
reporting that the whistleblower
complaint involves a phone call where
the president made a promise to a
foreign leader still Schiff said the
threshold for congressional notification
was met and the intelligence chief
blocked it was an urgent matter the
Director of National Intelligence has
made the unprecedented decision not to
share the complaint with Congress on
Twitter President Trump called the
claims quote another fake news story and
referring to the fact that other
officials were likely listening to his
calls quote is anybody dumb enough to
believe that I would say something
inappropriate with a foreign leader will
on such a potentially heavily-populated
call American leaders are often measured
by what they tell foreign leaders then
President Obama famously told the
outgoing Russian president he'd have
quote more flexibility to negotiate a
defense issue after the election today
the house Minority Leader was skeptical
I know the media always wants to rush
when they think something
sensationalists and nine times out of
ten we find out a lot of that's not true
I think the New York Times has
experienced that just in the last week
the new whistleblower complaint may
further stress the relationship between
the intelligence community and the
administration there are remaining legal
questions over whether Acting DNI
McGuire can share intelligence from
executive branch communications we do
know that the Department of Justice has
been involved in the decision to
withhold that information from Congress
we do not know because we cannot get an
answer to the question about whether the
White House is also involved in
preventing this information from coming
to Congress the Acting Director of
National Intelligence is scheduled to
publicly testify next week committee
Democrats say they are willing to go to
court over the issue while Republicans
called out shift statements as extreme
adding they are taking a wait-and-see
attitude on the complaint Brett Kevin
thank you